millions of years ago Earth looked very
different
all the continents were fused into one
teeming with life both beautiful and
terrifying
when you think of prehistoric times you
might picture a T-Rex rampaging through
the jungle with its razor-sharp teeth
but even before the dinosaurs there were
other giant creatures ruling the Earth
yeah welcome to the Permian period
this epic started 300 million years ago
back then our planet had one
supercontinent Pangea surrounded by a
world ocean called pantherlassa
the Permian period began at the end of
an ice age when temperatures were much
cooler than today
then during early Permian days Earth
warmed to a lush environment with a
diversity of plants and a rapid
evolution of insect and animal life
only as you probably know everything is
Ever Changing on our Blue Marble
over the next 50 million years Earth
kept growing hotter and drier eventually
the most deadly event in the history of
our planet wiped out nearly everything
that ever lived here
scientists call this event the great
dying and it was the most catastrophic
mass extinction event the Earth has ever
seen and the Earth has seen five of them
but before we get to all this Doom and
Gloom let me take you on an Epic Journey
Back in Time
here in the Permian period some of the
most incredible species that roamed our
young Planet are about to emerge
if you could time travel nearly 300
million years into the past you'd land
smack dab in the middle of the
supercontinent Pangea
Earth's smaller continents would have
just finished colliding with each other
to form this enormous land mass taking
up one third of the planet's surface
there was likely less oxygen in the air
than there is now but it still might be
able to breathe
oh and bring a jacket because it would
likely be chilly with some areas
averaging no more than a Brisk four
degrees Celsius
but don't worry things will soon start
heating up
by the end of the early Permian the Ice
Age was on its way out and Pangea was
becoming a lush world
plants and animals started to thrive
this was a volcanic World violent
eruptions changed the climate shaped the
landscape and paved the way for
evolution
when giant swamp forests began drying
out plant life had to adapt and so
290 million years ago Earth saw the very
first seed bearing plants called
gymnosperms
these plants carried seeds on their
cones and they spread across the
supercondent like wildfire
the ancient evergreen forest of the
early Permian was hiding something
familiar
just like today you could find cicadas
and beetles piercing and sucking on the
plants and the cutest of them all
cockroaches
only these weren't the Cockroaches you
know today
these prehistoric Vermin were gigantic
the size of birds
but despite their size cockroaches never
ruled prehistoric land and that's good
news am I right
no something much more fascinating was
roaming Pangea the now extinct ancestor
of primitive mammals Dimetrodon
this animal was as fascinating as it was
terrifying
encountering a dimetrodon would be quite
a sight to behold
this ancient lizard grew to five meters
long and weighed 225 kilograms
it had a large sail running down its
spine
scientists think this sale helped the
reptile regulate its body temperature
soaking up warmth during the daytime and
dissipating excess heat during the
cooler nights
it would walk toward you like a
crocodile and act like a total Menace
dimetrodon was an apex predator of its
time
watch out for a mix of sharp and flat
teeth that would slice you open and
grind you up
in the middle Permian period other
mammal-like reptiles took over the
planet the rap SIDS they had strong jaws
with sharp teeth and a somewhat upright
stance thanks to their legs being
situated underneath their bodies
the rapid reptiles varied from the five
meter long likely omnivorous
deuterasaurus to the five times smaller
meat-eating lycanops
you could beat plenty more thoraxids if
you stuck around for another 20 million
years
during the middle Permian period Earth
kept getting hotter the average global
temperature on Pangea grew to about 25
degrees Celsius and volcanoes were
spitting greenhouse gases out into the
atmosphere
due to the changing climate sea levels
were shifting but marine life found ways
to thrive
if you were to take a dip in the
prehistoric super ocean you'd be
swimming alongside ancient sharks and
bony primitive fish
many more complex marine species came
and went as the environment kept
changing
in the late Permian period you could
have a friendly encounter with another
reptile listrosaurus
these looked like a cross between a
lizard and a pig but unlike all the
scary prehistoric monsters out there
listrosaurus was a herbivore it was just
one meter long and had powerful front
legs for burrowing
soon another cute mammal-like lizard
evolved the synodont
the synodont looked like a giant rodent
it was about one meter long had whiskers
and fed on small animals and insects
now during this time something bad was
brewing in the air
a large amount of volcanic activity was
displacing oxygen from the atmosphere
scientists think there was as little as
10 percent oxygen in the air compare
that to 21 today
you'd have a hard time breathing in that
environment
and the temperature kept rising and
Rising
with an average temperature of about 28
degrees Celsius this Lush prehistoric
world was turning into an oven
all good things must come to an end and
sadly this period came to a particularly
brutal one
about 252 million years ago about 90
percent of all plant and animal life was
wiped out
this tragic moment is called the Great
dying and it was Earth's most
devastating mass extinction event
scientists still debate what caused this
catastrophic Extinction most theories
suggest it was the result of explosive
volcanic activity
as huge volcanic eruptions swept the
continent massive amounts of Ash were
Unleashed into the atmosphere
so much Ash that it blocked out most if
not all of the incoming sunlight and
with no sunlight global temperatures
dropped suddenly
plants couldn't perform their
photosynthetic processes and died off
and without plants the very basis of
their food chain animals soon followed
things got worse before they got better
because of all the carbon dioxide
emitted during the volcanic eruptions
global temperatures rose again and not
just to where they were but higher much
higher
and this caused the super ocean to lose
most of its oxygen and unable to breathe
a majority of the Permian sea animals
perished
eventually over 95 percent of marine
species and more than 70 percent of land
animals became extinct
this mass extinction event could make
you sad enough to want to bring back all
the animals that have ever gone away
dinosaurs too
but that's a story for another
what if